how am i gonna juggle doing vegas having
a baby
katy perry was that the vegas
confirmation we've been looking for
ah that's what you get far away
can't happen
that's right katie let it slip talking
to us a few days ago but
now it's official she's heading over to
her first ever eight show
vegas residency starting in december
also hitting the strip
her american idol co-judge luke bryan
he's doing six shows in february next
year
come on come on come on luke and i will
be seeing each other
is this a luke and katie in vegas double
residency moment
katie would never sign off on that by
the way katie and luke are just two of
the four founding performers at the new
resorts world las vegas casino where
carrie underwood will also make her
vegas debut in december
hi there it's celine celine dion the
queen of vegas rounds out this cast of
headliners
two years after wrapping her legendary
1000 plus show residency
she's making her return in november see
you then
hope so
you